tanner you you were so excited about
that dance tanner took complete control
there's a whole part of the dance that
tanner does at the beginning that got
cut like there was more to that dance
sequence i've danced for years so it was
nice to kind of like get back into that
cobra kai is back for season four and
you guys stepped up your fights even
higher tanner i feel like you've upped
your gymnastics game this year
this is a bit yeah he's just showing off
his gymnastics game he's always been mad
talented he's just like now he's just
fully letting it happen it's awesome for
the ladies i've got to tell you the prom
fight scene was by far my favorite scene
that we have seen in this show what was
it like kicking butt in those gowns
awesome
favorite part was like i think peyton
and i were comparing notes as because
you know we knew like prom prom prom
everyone's talking about prom and then
like getting up to it i feel like i kept
going to pain and being like didn't you
dress did you just that's the fact that
we're wearing heels like i think he's
adding tulle under mine but i mean like
my dress was originally a full-length
pink ball gown like i looked like a
barbie birthday cake and so they kept
like shortening it they're like in order
to see your legs kicking we need to go
short or shorter i was like how short
are we going like how much can we get
away with this thing evan peyton's out
there in a freaking swimsuit with a
trail
it was incredible yeah and they gave me
these huge heels to fight in which was a
first for sure usually we're barefoot in
the dojo but they wanted the height
difference between tory and sam to be
just you know massive so i had these
huge stilettos on i'm like what point in
the fight can we get these off because
this is insane like kicking at mary's
head and that big of it like a spiky
heel just felt terrifying and um yeah i
was basically in a bathing suit and it
was super low cut so wardrobe i'm just
like make sure that everything is secure
and in because this is a family show
well peyton and tanner what was more fun
for you guys the fight sequence at prom
or the dance sequence cause y'all got
some moves
i'm gonna say dance sequence uh
because i've danced for years so it was
nice to kind of like get back into that
um and just and just perform a little
bit also to the prom night fight whole
thing it was a very long night it was
very i mean i can't say anything because
i was in a suit and i had like long
johns on and all kinds of stuff so it
was very very cold for me so i can't
imagine what it was like for them
it was like 30 degrees outside and
the pool uh was heated at the beginning
of the night but not by the time we went
into it that was the rough one but it
was so worth it tanner you you were so
excited about that dance tanner took
complete control he went into
choreographer mode in the planning
mode give me full credit for that one
there's a whole part of the dance that
tanner does at the beginning that got
cut like there was more to that dance
sequence i have like bts footage because
i was cheering them on the whole time i
was like i know i shouldn't as samantha
but like as mary i love you guys this is
so cute no fighting until the tournament
we'll settle this on the mat i want to
talk about the finale it was so exciting
as a female fan to see that epic girl
versus girl showdown seeing these
amazing women finally come to a head in
the all valley tournament mary what did
that mean to you to see that you guys
were gonna be really the main event i
cried when we got the script initially i
i'm gonna get choked up now thinking
about it when i got the script initially
and there was a lot of debate there were
like several different versions that i
think they had full scripts like usually
there's a lot of different versions that
they're when they're writing they're
like well it could go this way or it
could go this way but i think they had a
legitimate full script of a version that
did not end the way that this season
does and so the version that we got then
every one of the producers came up to to
me and i'm sure you two peyton going did
you see it did you see that you guys are
the ones you guys decide the fate of the
valley and we had this like just me and
peyton like going into that fight felt
so freaking cool like i felt like an
absolute warrior also peyton and i've
worked our butts off for five years now
doing stunts that like we've worked to
get to have this kind of payoff it was
incredible to get to stand on that stage
and we had the actual audience in the
audience and we walked up there and we
got to like be announced as like and the
bones are bad at like it was so freaking
cool
i was like shaking i like the craziest
adrenaline rush it was anyway i could
talk all day it was the coolest moment
peyton how does that make you feel
though knowing that we saw tori win but
it seems like her victory was bought and
paid for like what was your reaction to
that i think there's a lot of moments my
jaw just dropped when i read that i mean
that was pretty pretty crushing just
feel like this character that's the one
thing like the whole season i'm just
like this is the one thing i'll prove to
myself you know my worth if i win the
all valley or you know this will finally
be the one thing i have ownership of i
don't really have anything going for me
except this one thing and then that one
thing is taken from her
so that was pretty that was pretty
heartbreaking tanner seeing the showdown
between robbie and former hawk was
really intense what was your reaction
though when you found out that robbie
was not able to cinch the wind that
broke my heart going into the season i
was like robbie's gotta win robbie's
gotta win he's he's he's been beat down
every single season and this is gonna be
his one thing and then i kept talking to
the writers and like mary said i think
there was multiple endings and they
decided on that ending and i got it i
was definitely reading i was like and
no he loses okay well great
this is
okay this is this is fine this is i'm
okay
but you know everything happens for a
reason and ultimately by the time i got
through that and then got to the very
ending scene with with me and johnny it
was actually for me a way bigger payoff
and was super happy that that the whole
relationship between him and johnny
seemed to kind of be going in the
direction of
being an actual father and son
uh so that it was much bigger payoff so
i ultimately at first i was like why is
he why is he not winning
but
it was nice
it happened the way it needed to